[Music]
and key cable top to amen
now who's ready
for other people
[Music]
what's up austin texas
it's great to be here watching people
date we're gonna
hopefully get some people to get married
today it is texas that's the only way
we're allowed to have sex anymore
so let's get on it okay
make a bit proud tonight
uh my name is hans kim i'm a regular on
kill tony a show that this show is
basically a ripoff of uh so we do one
minute of dating and then we interview
the dates and then find out who's
secretly a trump supporter or got
vaccinated or
you know has is unemployed and lives
with his mom
it's usually the dude but uh we're gonna
have fun we have a bunch of names in the
bucket
men and female no lgbtqs this isn't a
trap just because governor abbott's here
in this city doesn't mean we're gonna
ban you and you know
don't say gay you i was just in florida
uh so
i'm a little
flirted out you know let's see
a lot of a lot of beautiful people here
anyways we're gonna watch some of you
guys date and i'm excited about it are
you guys excited about it make some
noise
awesome
this guest that we have tonight is from
new york a new york city comedian very
talented comedian please get out for
gina hyena
[Music]
hello gina hey excited to be here
excited to watch people date tonight
yeah i haven't been on a date in like a
year so it'll be fun to wow
yeah that seems like a choice it
absolutely is i found out that i have
nothing but bad advice the longest uh
relationship i ever had was with the
pimp actually true story
yeah and then uh after that i just was
very defensive and take out my
frustrations on men because i think men
liking me is threatening so i got
nothing but bad giant boner right now
what uh was this your pimp or your boss
uh what do you mean oh no oh i didn't
make her call you a [ __ ] oh no no no
it's fine it blew anyway
i'm too much of a nerd for it to mean
anything
no i he didn't pimp me out i uh he was
actually half jewish so he saved all the
money which sucked oh that's next
combination
made in a super lab exactly italian jew
perfect pimp yeah save the money good
backhand you know
exactly what you wanted sounds like a
crime yeah uh we got blank we're blinged
out uh sponsored by gold uh if you
couldn't tell i'm wearing this so
naturally because
uh i'm i'm living that lifestyle of
being so natural right now i know
i feel really natural
um but yeah we got a couple names in
here written in sherp do we have four
men in here right now
we're gonna watch four men date each
other
well the first woman coming up is angel
or angel
angel okay
come on up here show us how it's done
who's the lucky
who's a lucky fella our lucky fellow is
david r
david curious and then that's poor
ramirez or rodriguez
angel with david r wow look at this
beautiful couple and one minute of
dating
go
hello how are you i'm good i'm david r
i'm angel nice to meet you it's very
nice to meet you where are you from i'm
originally from hoboken new jersey
oh i'm from illinois
that's okay i mean are you from chicago
though at least like no there's good
food no no good food i'm like 45 minutes
outside of the city i don't like to be
fake and say i'm from chicago okay i
mean that's like saying you're from
houston but like you're actually from
katy
i don't know where that is that's bad i
mean it means something here but like
whatever okay
yeah so so what do you do uh i'm working
at ey doing consulting
oh consulting's [ __ ] huge right now
you guys make a lot of money for like
anything like it's very ambiguous you do
whatever you're like probably selling
children oh
no what about you what do you do
uh so i'm retired
so yeah that's pretty ambiguous but i
just started a company uh not too long
ago so so i own a recruiting and
talent acquisition company right now oh
what do you recruit
everything that's part of recruiting so
we can recruit everything it depends on
the clientele
and then they come in
and time give it up
even r
and i'm angel
david does the r stand for retired or
recruiting uh
it's both it's very flexible it depends
on clientele he's very flexible
are you also a pimp because that's also
a no i am going to talk about you though
so i mean he's recruiting same same
prostitutes
so what uh what do you like about your
new job you're out there recruiting
people oh that i'm [ __ ] doing
something i was so bored
you're bored being retired at the age of
24
23 yeah
family dead family what happened i have
a good family
dead no they're still alive i didn't
have to do that what a catch angel his
family is still alive yeah
yeah
what do you think about this beautiful
man with his own company
yeah you're consulting david r had a lot
of opinions about consulting were any of
them correct
no yeah no we don't tell children but
it is kind of ambiguous i don't know
that's the kind of word you learn in
consulting it's ambiguous yes
a lot of syllables it's sales
did you go to college yeah
nice
what college miami of ohio
okay those are two different places
isn't there it's in ohio but it's the
university of miami it's just like a
[ __ ]
multiverse of madness
it's [ __ ] insane
they're like how do we improve ohio
let's go to another city and steal their
college it's the miami that snows
look that's how you saw it miami that
snows
we was founded before the city of miami
was so
no
little history lesson for us
how did you feel about the date with
david
i don't know
are we bored as [ __ ]
you don't know were you bored as us he
has his own company
he doesn't
i've never done this before what's your
deepest darkest secret
i don't i lost like the third darkest
like
used to lose a lot of hamsters as a kid
oh hamsters always have the worst death
ray one time i
like left him and then my parents were
taking care of him and then he like
escaped and got into his ball and then
it like landed on top and then he like
couldn't run anywhere and then he died
oh what's his name hear me r.i.p hammy
[ __ ] that good news is you can't have an
abortion but she'll kill your baby
anyways
they'll escape through a ball
no respect and hamster death that's the
worst
oh so sad no i had a bunch of hamsters
also david r what's your history with
pets like
uh they're good i just gave away my dog
it wasn't my choice my girlfriend didn't
like it oh you suck more and more every
time
do you have a girlfriend it was small i
do and you came out of the show
uh
consulting purposes yeah it's very
insulted your girlfriend and she was
like get rid of the dog yeah
she was like you could either like say
goodbye to me or the dog and i was like
well like the dog's only going to live
10 years and you're probably going to
live a lot oh that's a red flag i hope
she's an iud i hope you guys never have
kids she's due to have my son in
december
congratulations
justin
couldn't be like no i'm gonna keep the
dog because like tickets to california
are only 200 bucks yeah you're retired
nuke that [ __ ] you have so much
responsibility being retired that you
can handle a dog she's catholic it's
it's not it's a non-starter you bro
she's i'm a
we're in the catechism does it say today
to pimp
mary magdalene dude i was following
other [ __ ]
yeah you found your little jesus
your italian jesus yeah he was jewish
though so who knows he's one of the
chosen people we'll find out
angel would you ever date a pimp
no
you went to college
gina is actually a neurosurgeon so i
used to work in spinal cord surgeries
and now i tell jokes
him slapped me too hard got a brain
injury
now i'm just silly
what a love story right better than
twilight
so david r do you do cocaine or do you
just have that polo
um
so i mean since the baby i'm
around cocaine but i don't do it anymore
your cocaine adjacent
yeah i'm cocaine adjacent that's cool
you have that permanent smile of a man
that is around cocaine all the time i
have the the weird conceited double
cowlick and like just all these polos i
just can't get rid of it you're a
beautiful man i no wonder you have a
beautiful girlfriend what were you doing
before you were retired at the age of 23
i worked for the department of defense
oh [ __ ] so you're in the military i was
in the military what branch i was in the
united states marine corps
wow war here [ __ ] boy that's what it is
is that the i thought it was
always no air force are all the soft
little [ __ ] [ __ ] dudes marines are
the [ __ ] boys always you guys are always
like eating crayons like [ __ ] hookers
they're about to die
yeah we live fast
how's your relationship with your mother
um
good
i don't know that's a
it's it's weird man right now my my
girlfriend hates me a little worried
about your mother i'm worried too
why did your girlfriend hate your mom
uh
so like she saw a text from my mom
where she was like you need to set
boundaries
like she's like doing some things now i
was like
i was ignoring her because she's like
your typical jewish mom and she's just
like way overboard
and like we did one thing and she was
like ooh you can't do that
that you're being gaslated by this girl
like you can't talk to your mom your mom
like you need to set boundaries and she
looked at your phone and was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this was before she convinced
me to get rid of my service dog
yeah your girlfriend sucks how good well
no how good is your girlfriend's [ __ ]
because you're putting up with some [ __ ]
dude i mean it's
look at it it's top tier yeah i see
that's right that's champ his pimp is
his girlfriend right now dude i went
through this in my 20s i've been trained
i've been trained well by her it seems
like it you're on a dating show with
somebody else
i'm supporting the show how hard would
she hit you right now
oh dude so hard there'd be weapons
involved
welcome to texas yeah what was your
dog's name that you gave away her name
was liberty
what a hero
twist on that kind of ironic yeah
what a twist
she literally made you give away your
liberty and [ __ ] ignore your my dad
still sends me pictures of her which is
like the best and you literally have a
woman here named angel that you're on
read the [ __ ] room bro
an ambiguous consulting yeah
angel would just would you ever make a
man give up his dog
no
what about a cat
uh
cats are different yeah
single guy
make it like no a guy with a cat is
weird though that's rare yeah it's weird
it's kind of a red flag i know you
definitely make him get rid of the
hamster
yeah
i think i i think i deserve to give
myself a second chance yeah like 10
years so another hamster in your life
not another david five no well he's
gonna break your heart but a hamster
you're going to break its heart by
killing it
yeah it's so cool that you sucked so bad
but we already know you're getting what
you deserve
what did i do
because you immediately asked a girl
like you're like you make a lot of money
oh i give a dog away immediately
like that sucks when you're like
consulting is a good job is what i see
you try to throw some shitty jokes about
selling kids or whatever the [ __ ] just
bomb it's ambiguous
you said you were retired at 23 yeah
that's such a douchey thing to say it's
so shitty
what does that mean you can retire at 20
do you have a lot of money saved up just
gonna uh
live comfortably
for
ever
okay
you collecting disability
uh i collect my retirement disability no
retirement you should i bet you'd pass
i bet i could because
for a [ __ ] nervous dog
but i don't know if my girlfriend
i don't have it anymore i got a service
girlfriend
what is like the kindest thing that you
did in your 24 years of life so far the
kindest thing i've done yeah for another
human
i've done a lot you gave a soccer ball
to some kids before you blew him up with
the drone
no so i was infantry so i was up close
and personal
nice
shaking hands kissing babies yeah
kissing babies kicking doors down you
know saying falling into airstrikes
different from drones
anyways i said something nice dude
you're distracting war crimes
i mean i've definitely saved some people
and then other than that i've like
donated like my my salary for like a
year because
to who
uh your girlfriend no to pet
it's actually ironic because it's called
pets for vets
it yeah oh i said for other humans
you're giving all your money away to
dogs and there's homeless people all
right well they get trained as service
animals for other vets and i like lived
in the hospital so i didn't need my
money do you think liberty thinks about
you i hope so i bet liberty's like
[ __ ] stoked actually i visited her
last week and it was it was the best
where was she she's in houston
who has her uh my dad
are your parents together
and you just they've been together for
like several years
oh oh my mom like travels a lot so she's
like never home
angel um what uh what's how's your
dating been in austin
honestly pretty shitty they're the worst
way
the dating apps are just like
and like where do you meet guys in
person here
um
the bar
which bar ooh which bra i like west six
what's next kung fu get you a country
yeah
and it was just like the vibes were just
off i don't know it's a bunch of white
dudes that look like they came from
golfing to like david
david the r stands for rainey
you go to east
coast
yeah
that's awesome you're you're you're too
good for dirty you know you're too rich
for e6 so you go to west six i do like
getting the free drinks on e6 like the
bouncers i like flag you in oh yeah
dirty yeah oh yeah that's worth it they
play the best music too they do they get
a little ratchet with it i'm down with
that yeah
what's this i mean yeah if you want a
guy with like a nice head of hair and
like a [ __ ] tech job all right
wait when did you move here um june oh
[ __ ] so you're a nunu
oh use a condom girl they all got [ __ ]
out here everybody be [ __ ] each other
oh everybody be [ __ ] each other it's
here it's so wild it's like the smallest
town i've ever been to you meet a guy
then like you guys go on a date together
and like five people like dab them up
and you're like the [ __ ] is that about
you know friendly ass yeah
yeah it's wild house and you're from
illinois
how is dating out there
shittier
like i'm not it's not like i wasn't from
chicago so it was like my like 30 000
people town like people from my [ __ ]
high school no yeah no they do drugs out
there
probably oh word okay yeah
everyone i went to high school with his
dad so that's what i heard i'm from
massachusetts they're all [ __ ]
heroined out just dead that's why i was
like well with your high school like and
you're like i just don't like them yeah
no
i did meet someone from my high school
yesterday though and it was like [ __ ]
disturbing yeah like yeah i was like i
gotta go so you went from illinois to
ohio that was a real lateral move
it was just how did you like the uh
exciting college town of ohio
oxford it's like middle of nowhere but
it was a great time like
yeah you can pretend you're in miami
have fun even though we're not in
florida so
which drugs did you have fun with
just weed i don't like to mess around
ohio party town
we got some schedule one weed
for this frat party what's your type
because i know it's not david r uh
tall
brunette
yeah okay you just need to grow a little
bit yeah it's a little bit of meat
vertically and like has like a plan in
life ooh that's nice because they just
retire at 23 and live in the government
that's a wealth
gave away my dog ignore my mom yeah
there's that but
oh yeah all right what what dating apps
are you on
tinder
hinge and bubble which one have you
liked the best so far bubble
right because you're in charge
and it's pretty cool i actually
sometimes i get like spiteful about that
because i'm old school and i like men to
start like the conversation and like
make reservations so i'm literally
already mad that i have to say hi first
that's just how it works yeah if i don't
know what to say i just say hey with a
smiley face um but it's perfect for
austin yeah they're all autistic nerds
i don't want to talk to my girl
can you talk to me first
what's the most autistic date you've
been on
well
there's this guy who like i thought we
had a really good time and then like he
like personally texts the next day and
then like we're like let's hang out this
weekend and then he just like never
texted me again [ __ ] that guy yeah and
like we were like gonna like go to
dinner or something and then like he
just like did not like have a solid plan
so we ended up like meeting at a bar
like 10 p.m on a thursday oh don't go to
that just don't show up if he does that
you're lonely yeah
well the good thing about nerds is that
they're used to rejection so you can
just
just be naked i'm a nerd
no that like the guy don't show up at 10
p.m just be like [ __ ] it
no you're gonna a call
dinner reservations david where do you
like to take your beautiful girlfriend
on dates uh
dates in austin
um there's this little italian place on
south lamar called it's italian
which is probably like the italian in
the city it's very uh on the nose
yeah like an italian restaurant for
children great pad thai it sounds like
it but every other italian restaurant in
the city is garbage just because i was
spoiled living in new york big facts big
yeah it's most the food here is garbage
and like it's it's so depressing
so if i want to go on a date i love
barbecue barbecue
the barbecue here is just too fatty
okay
that's horrible i hate fat food yeah
i love it lean and with lots of broccoli
uh
thank you for moving from new jersey you
know with your
gluten-free diet and your girlfriend
uh how did you meet your beautiful gf
uh
she was the bottle service girl at unbar
unbelievable
yeah it just gets better and better oh
what a rainy street love story
i met a guy he's retired and he's only
like 24.
i think he's the one i'm gonna make him
get rid of his dog i think that's how it
went down yeah so what did she do
especially different did she like oh man
she's in real estate now
um
she was like almost the same thing
uh
yeah but i mean she
just you know what does she do that
caught your eye besides say yes
[ __ ] sparklers she was funny
she was super nice she loved my dog i
feel like i kind of got catfished
because she was like i love your dog so
much i was like i love her too
like she's great
and then like she moved in and then
everything changed what is his name
no this is being recorded
well she doesn't want you getting other
[ __ ] she knows how well it works
she's like let's get rid of his one and
only redeeming quality i mean i i guess
i don't know that's wild you met a
bottle service girl and you're like
friendly for some reason
and funny and i know she knew a lot of
my friends
never mind weird that's not a reg
it's it's not going well what's the
funny thing she said
oh like a like of remembering a joke she
said
no it's like she she doesn't make jokes
she just says funny things okay like
they're not well crafted is she like a
carl is she like a marx brother does she
do physical comedy no it's it's more
like
he
she's really good at observational or
like like in the moment insult comedy
and i'm like that's that was pretty
funny where is she from uh corpus
christi yeah
not what i was explaining
texas as [ __ ]
yeah catholic another jew moving to
texas stealing our women
just
dating until she moved in
is she really pregnant yeah oh is that
why she moved in
no
so we're together for like a year and a
half is that a good timeline
you got your bro in the back validating
it yeah yeah that's when i disappeared
from like all social life that's always
a good sign how you know your friend's
happy
yeah
i haven't seen him for six months yet so
you guys are a pandemic relationship
yeah who gave who coveted first oh she
gave me covet
what a [ __ ] yeah she's the reason why i
got vaccinated uh you get herpes no i
didn't get chlamydia five times in one
month though yeah you're a marine no way
yeah with that i had to go to court
because of it
it's important because
chlamydia so in the marine corps if you
get chlamydia three times
in a row they kick you out and i got it
five times in one month
that's literally i told you marines are
[ __ ] they're like and then i had to
explain like scientifically and like
chronologically yeah that's you
to a doctor and an admiral how i got
clementines
what the disease was [ __ ] you dude
no
it was great they're mansplaining
chlamydia no because they they recorded
it for like
legal reasons and i got to keep it so i
got to keep like you had to keep the
chlamydia so i don't know that got
treated for free i got to keep the video
of me like well sir like
i had sex with this girl and i had sex
with this girl and then i went back to
this girl and it was pretty much just
the same girl but you get it and he's
like no i don't and i was like saying
okay
fool me once
he was pretty much just like you're
stupid but like five times i need to
talk to your pimp boyfriend yeah
i'm pimp boyfriend's landlord now his
jewish side took over
the good side has won
the italian side has been we eventually
straighten out
oh yeah you suck dude
angel's great angel angel everyone give
it up for angel
she did tolerate you for a minute
angel is there anything you could say to
david r to maybe help him with his
girlfriend
oh my god like don't get stabbed girl
like it i just i'm still just like
flabbergasted that you got rid of your
dog like that's just i can't get over
that
that's worse yeah it's
i'm in the center
i would say listen to your mom unless
your mom's like crazy but oh no my mom's
great okay yeah but just like [ __ ] her
because you don't want to like
listen to her
my mom yeah isn't she the one that told
you to set boundaries or did your
girlfriend tell you that well no
so like she did say set boundaries but
like it was out of the blue so i could
kind of see
why she got mad but then she like
it grew into this like paranoia
to where like any time my mom texted me
it was just like what the [ __ ] she's
saying like blah blah blah blah and i'm
like
she's seeing if like my costco
membership is enough like it sounds
super healthy yeah okay
she's gonna have a great update i'm glad
i'm glad you're having a kid now yeah
and then she was like your dog breathes
too much and i was like that's why you
got rid of your dog no she like barked
at her once but it was for a good reason
yeah i'll bet you got rid of it because
she's a [ __ ] demon
you don't need an abortion you need an
exorcism dude see you know i i contacted
the rabbi at the ll and he said he
doesn't do that exorcisms no
catholics
yeah yeah go find a catholic girlfriend
maybe uh i think that's just get
chlamydia from her something i don't
know i'm working i'm negotiating
extremely hard to bring in the dog back
i'm this close
to getting the dog back isn't it your
house dude it everything is mine you
know what a [ __ ] dude yeah
yeah well you know
welcome to texas hopefully uh you guys
have a nice traditional relationship
yeah it'll be something
you're gonna do great david r uh just
leave angel alone because she's she's a
beautiful soul she's an angel yeah
she doesn't need you giving her
chlamydia
thank you that's been cured for a while
now and also the universe is sending you
like a thousand signs today so maybe
like listen to one of them
maybe i'm going to negotiate i'm going
to lobby harder to get the dog back
you're going to have a
male or female child or can we say
something it's a boy
uh it's a boy do on christmas oh we're
gonna have another comedian because he's
gonna have a shitty upbringing thank you
for supporting comedy uh and please
don't assume the gender of your baby
until they can consent let me tell you
but give it up for david r and on angel
that was awesome you guys we got two
more women left if any women wants to
sign up we could really use you
you can have a boyfriend as david r has
shown us jill deserves to come up here
three more times
angel's gonna [ __ ] someone tonight we
got
a man named donald coming up donaldo
and our name is marie claire
marie claire sounds like
yeah
sounds like a jewelry company marie
calendar like a magazine too she's got
two first names that's how white she is
marie claire going on a date with donald
hey there nice to meet you nice to meet
you how long have you been awesome um
since june as well all right so what
made you move here uh i have a job here
i work at arrive logistics okay what's
your role i'm a freight broker what is a
freight record here um so basically i
sell
hopefully not drones loads truckloads
truckloads yeah so like i work with like
chipotle and
pabst and they give me loads and i get
truckers to drive it basically that's it
i like that was that
were you thinking about doing that job
for a long time or like what was your no
growing up like what were you thinking
of doing
um being a stay-at-home wife
but
now i want to be a professor so okay
well hunkers make good money yeah they
do i mean i'm not driving the trucks but
trick freight brokers make good money
yeah what about yourself right now i'm a
technical recruiter
for uh lyft
word word that's sick yeah okay but
professorship like are you still on that
path are you still gonna go back yeah
yeah yeah hopefully it happens next year
and then um
don't know from there just kind of doing
whatever i want what do you want to
teach uh entrepreneurship or um
management
and time
give it up for murray claire
y'all are sweet harley much better
this is the perfect date
ten out of ten you guys made all the
right moves you didn't try to explain
her job to her you let her explain her
job
she's
way better than uh yeah open-ended
questions that was nice you took the
lead that was cool
where'd you move here from indianapolis
oh i've been out there once the biggest
thing is like the lucas oil field in st
elmo's indy 500 no i was i worked for
eli lilly for a bit
yeah
yeah yeah but it's nice out there
everybody's super nice you guys got
great stuff who's your hospitality yeah
[ __ ] yeah oh that's why you're studying
entrepreneurship
because there's like a lot of
hospitality around there
sorta yeah
let me tell you who you are see i pulled
a [ __ ] david sorry guys
donald you heard that she was a freight
loader and he didn't make any sex jokes
congratulations thank you thank you i
got some freight you could load i don't
know
that was a world-class world-class move
donald uh what uh what's your dating
been like recently you are you out there
i am not too good but
you're not too good
i'll be the judge of that
where are you from donald uh originally
new jersey
good good side of new jersey
oh okay yeah good part the yen and the
yang of new jersey on stage tonight you
can be good just because you're from
jersey doesn't mean you have to you know
assault
your dog or whatever
whatever what's uh
what's your favorite thing about austin
so far
i actually like the food i think it has
a pretty good diversity in food
being a diversity
you're you're our diversity tonight
you're the only black person here
what uh where do you see the diversity
i mean it's not just barbecue there is
italian here there's korean there's
chinese there's uh
again mediterranean as well like food
indian yeah okay
they're good enough for yeah
a city of its size how long you've been
here
five years oh [ __ ] and still how how old
are you 31. oh okay did you have
relationships during that time here yeah
a few okay what was the worst one
you mean a bottle service girl
no
smarter than that
i don't know i don't think it even been
bad i think they did things yeah
i went to seattle for two years
oh so you've just been in all the [ __ ]
cities huh
dallas fort worth arlington then here
seattle back here oh for what what do
you do that made you do all that well
for work mainly for lyft oh i changed
companies oh i've worked for amazon for
google give move
promotion
there's really promotions and changing
companies still making moves you guys
are both so nice and soft-spoken i
immediately feel like too much and you
should talk more
it's so scary yeah this is a racist
worst nightmare right now
you guys are actually getting along
yeah you are marie you said you want to
be a stay-at-home mother
i used to but now i love you yeah girl
thank you
but now i don't think i have
children so
that's why i want to be professor not a
teacher stay-at-home person is what i
want yeah yeah yeah yeah basically yeah
so you don't you don't have patience for
children so you just want to be
surrounded by them all day but they're
like older it's not the same it's not
the same so you hate them when they're
younger yes yeah these suck when they're
younger these are [ __ ]
the worst yeah yeah even children
it's like they can only think about
themselves well yeah you guys hate kids
over where you're from right yeah we
nuke them just awesome
only if they're women
the men we like
i don't know why it's just how we are
because they don't want to be
stay-at-home wives
yeah
so uh what uh what what would a typical
day look like for you as a stay-at-home
wife um
i mean
i'll just like
say what my mom does but shop
shop yeah
yeah parents every now and then play
with my dolls you have the perfect name
for shopping you can go to class
no so
you go to marie calendars
what uh what would you shop for
shoes i love shoes
we have a similar style and glasses so i
i'll take that as a compliment cool
what's your favorite shoe brand
probably jeffrey campbell i love some
jeffree campbells right yeah if you had
like unlimited budget what would be your
favorite brand
i don't know
i mean it would probably still be
jeffrey campbell i don't need something
too expensive okay word see some
simplicity somebody wipe this chick up
if she's like
because i'm like louie
you're like no no it's fine it's
whatever she doesn't even spend that
much money
that's true perfect
so uh
donald
where did you get the name donald from
my dad i'm actually the same dad you
come from a long line of donald's
yeah long enough three what do you think
about the donald
his dad
trump
no comment no comments he's still in the
date
you still got this with this white woman
you're perfect to meet her parents no
comment if you all saw each other on a
dating app would you swipe right or left
i don't really use dating apps so oh
that was politically awesome
she's too busy shopping
she's swiping right on purses and shoes
i didn't ask if you use them girl
that's it if
um well also i'm 21 so oh
we already called the cops donald you're
going to jail
so do they have dating app in
indianapolis or is that more of a
one-horse town
um
it depends on where you are
where you got internet service
yeah that's rare you got to play extra
out in the farm for that but um i mean
they do
i don't really i wasn't really in india
in the time that i would want to be on a
dating app if that makes sense yeah i
also go to miami of ohio so no way you
guys all went to the same college she's
my roommate so yeah
all right
so you guys know all about each other's
dating history
sort of
you hear it through the walls uh that's
cool
so uh donald are you on the apps
no not anymore
is this your beautiful girlfriend right
there no that's one of my best friends
oh yeah
those those are great too has he had a
chick that you like couldn't stand like
has he ever had one that you're like
what was which one was it is there a
particular one
oh tell us about cassie why did she suck
uh cooking was terrible um
indecisive what did she make that you're
like jesus
she tried to make a lobster mac and
cheese oh no
i'm sure it was really good like she's
followed the recipe and everything but
then at the very end she wanted to add
some color to it she'd throw raisins in
there or some chips
close the celery
oh
the crunchy celery with the soft mac and
cheese
that's what it was missing that's why
she was dating you is because she wanted
to add some color to it
marie do you cook i'm a terrible cook oh
she admits it thank god i do well
luckily you'll have a lot of time being
a stay-at-home mom you know i'll perfect
the wife i can't cook
you're only 21.
go look on the internet we have that
here in austin
what uh what would you cook if you could
cook will say i make a mean buffalo mac
and cheese
cheese way better than lobster mac and
cheese
make very good buffalo mac and cheese um
if i could cook something
i don't know actually
like
stuffed
shell
does that make sense of stuff
my aunt makes really good stuff shells
like really really really good hey so
it's just the greatest
what was your last date before this
um
i think that was in 2018. so i'm worried
i feel that yeah my high school
boyfriend oh [ __ ] decided not to date in
college
never i don't have time so yeah just
time for that what does he do
no idea
wait you don't know what he does for
work
you're she was 18. i was 18.
i also like stay at home
facebook
you didn't keep in touch with them
no euro tabs
zero tab zero tabs his mother still
follows me on instagram but
you gotta get those followers exactly
damn what was the date in 2018 so you
said it was your high school boyfriend
that's a child that's one yeah a girl i
know um
oh see you're not on the alps out here
either not really only when i relied on
hans came over here to just get up yeah
come
i'll help you ladies
uh but yeah you uh you have a very
soothing voice have you ever narrated
any documentaries or
yeah you can read an audio book yeah
you're right
no what's the most excited you've ever
been have you ever yelled at a are you
saying i'm like very monotonous
not necessarily it's i heard that yeah i
can be i'll be more excited now
but
i don't know i don't really show that
much motion no way no
yeah no we noticed
donald what nationality are you
is it just like white for like seven
generations yes
german dutch whatever just been here for
forever yes donald what's the racial
makeup of your dating history
that's a wild question of everything
from
black white
it's like all the time he's free white
black japanese korean he's like
yeah this sounds like the restaurants
you go to
are getting bottle service at these
restaurants
so well i usually try to like ask girl
like what her favorite restaurants are
so that's how i know
whether it's a lot of brands that's nice
yeah that's his move
teacher master marie what's your
favorite restaurant
um i don't know i really haven't been
here that long um
to like try to verna
taverna yeah tavern is good for brunch
too
but yeah i went there for instagram
photos to send your ex's mom
no look what i'm doing [ __ ]
your son who's holding me holding me
back
so why haven't you dated since your high
school days
like i said i don't really have that
much time i'm a busy gal kinda so you're
busy with school what else yeah um at
school i have three jobs and i
what the
do you have a girl
i'm a bouncer one of them
i know that one throws people off i'm a
bouncer uh
bouncing children
i got the bars you know i get to stand
with the big staff t-shirt and kick
people out sometimes
so i can be scary not really but
i probably wouldn't do anything unless
my manager came over and was like yo
this girl this girl get her and then i
just were like hey can you leave one for
me
that version of a bouncer it's like
usually like taoism or something like
that it's been on the other side before
i know somebody was like yeah let's
assume donald is acting uh up a storm
like he's just drinking he's just
pushing people he's he's just being
classic donald trump kind of racist
how would you how would you balance
donald from your establishment
honestly i'd probably talk to his
friends first and be like get him a
water get him out of here
um so you're so discontent in the ranks
you'd make
that's that's the next level i like
logical about i know
you're getting deep in the social and
emotional psychological like call your
mother she's like the doctor phil of
bouncer
i felt balanced but i repaired my
relationship with my dog
why do you think you're acting this way
here
everybody needs an outlet so
that's so funny what are your other jobs
um i also
help teach classes so i'm like a ua but
some of the classes i do teach every now
and then and then i also nanny which is
ironic because i don't really like kids
how old are the kids two oh [ __ ] that's
kid kid but she's cute because it's my
my boss for my other job it's just her
daughter so like i have some sort of
connection so that like changes it how
many parallels do you find between
nannying and bouncing
what was the would you say there's a lot
of parallels between nanny and bouncing
bro yeah yes people with like
don't know what they're doing so
i'm leaning out on emotion yeah yeah
it's kind of easier with a two-year-old
sometimes
i can just grab them
yeah maybe some of them in a closet i
don't know oh my god we're bouncing
it's this janky bar called pachinko
let's go rob it
no you're probably good there's nothing
in the
nothing in there what's the craziest
thing you saw at pachinko's
that i did or that somebody else that
someone else did
i don't know it doesn't get too long
what did you do there
i fall all the time that's it
hey pachinko with the falling bouncers
can't tell if the patrons are drunk or
the bouncer's drunk you boston weird
donald what uh so what did you do for
lyft you're some sort of tech guy tech
recruiter oh that's all for well if you
need a guy to help you i know david r is
in the industry
dave's getting started trying to hire
recruiters
he couldn't afford what i do though oh
i'm like that yeah
donald trump [ __ ] you veteran
you're too poor
what uh what what have you done for lyft
so far have you uh recruited any uh
cool drivers or do you recruit for like
their tech their offices the tech team
for the corporate offices so software
engineers and product managers
do you stand in for their brochures to
show that they have diversity
yeah they actually have really good
diversity but you know how many of them
are citizens
how many of you yeah like are any of
them like from a different country that
they need like a visa or something like
the drivers or the candidates the tech
guys yeah a lot a few depends on like
what job family but yeah gotcha
usually they have already moved here
worked for other companies they've been
here for a number of years what
nationality do you see the most with
like tech recruiting
for sure asian so yeah being
chinese japanese
all the
asian countries
okay i'm right here
all the e's i'd say maybe if this
doesn't work out you know
i'll make sure there's no chemical or uh
chemistry of romance in your office
always kill it
but uh what would you say to marie
claire over here to show that you're
you're eligible you're an eligible
bachelor
what would i say to show her that i'm an
eligible bachelor yeah
i don't know i don't even know if she
are you single
yeah oh very
she hasn't dated since she was 18.
you're back
you can let her know the latest trends
in dating now
maybe ask for availability and
when next time she wants are you trying
to recruit her from
what's your availability claire what's
your calendar look like
you have room for an interview slash
date like i said i'm a busy person so
maybe
well three jobs a day will keep the
dicks away that's for sure
uh i'm gonna fund my shopping somehow so
would you fund a stay-at-home wife
yeah absolutely
good morning
good man give it to donald
good man
hell yeah
would you guys go on a date after this
i'm done dating in austin oh not okay
you guys have so much in common
yeah 10 years difference that's
too much for me
cool cool donald wants to stay home wife
i'll
talk to you
later it up for donald and marie claire
they went on a date
and they're still not [ __ ]
we're gonna find some people [ __ ]
tonight that's the point of the show
right yeah it's the porn
next up we got
other people favorite grant
coming up is there a regular yeah this
guy is pretty lonely
he's been coming from years grant he
needs it grants
all right and our lucky lady is melinda
melinda
here she comes donald's friend
melinda's best friend [ __ ] yeah
we like donald so we're going to like
melinda melinda
and grant
wait
what my name is not melinda
what's up my middle name is it mirinda
and i hate it
wait real name is jenny jenny
my first name i got excited though i
thought it was like former wife of bill
gates melinda gates yeah because
don't tell jokes on the date
we even started this is why he's single
and go one minute
hey how's your relationship with your
mom it's actually really good um me and
her very close we go on vacations
together
okay
yeah what about you and uh your father
how are you doing
you know i haven't seen him like
literally
15 years dang it's just going horrible
well my relationship with my dad's
pretty bad too so we've got that in
common right yeah
yeah what's the craziest thing your
dad's ever done
i literally wouldn't know
okay um
well
my dad's a narcissistic sociopath so
that's
also hot but okay yeah it's genetic
you ready to get out of here
yeah actually
no just kidding how long have you been
in austin
i've been here exactly year i moved from
dallas that's cute yeah where are you
from seattle
i know okay
end time
grant give it up for grant and jenny
graham what do you have against seattle
um it's not really seattle actually it
was portland which is like adjacent to
seattle yeah it's only three hours away
yeah
i was almost molested actually as a
child in uh portland which is just too
close to seattle i guess okay that's
them well how come they didn't do it um
he started making jokes he turned around
let me tell you uh i was on a
i was on a subway actually with my dad a
trimet there's not a subway in portland
or it's like a train car it went
underground is that a subway
it was probably the max the max anyway i
was on the max when i got molested uh it
was
a couple dudes actually sitting right
next to me and my father
and the guy on the intro was getting
really close to me on the in row and he
was like
asking me too many personal questions
about myself and he eventually like
started grabbing on me my dad's not
doing anything grabbing on you
like don't touch it
he's rubbing your legs
on you dude yeah
just like getting really close to my dad
just not doing anything to do that like
oh he's making friends
he's just networking he's networking
like it's all about meeting new people
your dad tried to sell you
yeah yeah pretty much and then what
happened
and he was like no thank you i think his
the guy's boyfriend got jealous
like me too [ __ ] where you weren't even
close to him molested but you're like a
guy looked at me too long
i think oh what a [ __ ] right i know he
was touching your legs
yes he any of the goods
i didn't i didn't get in too much i was
i was uh i was a young
innocent boy i didn't know you were
touched unwantedly i was i was
unconsensually touched on the train so
the story is a man touch your leg on the
train like when you're five years old
no [ __ ] dude look at you but like you
didn't ask any personal questions
pretend you're on a train dude have some
romance
and you turned that into i almost got
molested are you also a sociopath like
your father are you just trying to play
on her i went at it earlier it was
foreshadowing
you weren't paying attention to the
story don't talk to me like come on
jenny
jenny you you heard that his dad was a
sociopath and you thought that was that
was pretty cool right
no
no
you didn't like that
what did you uh oh god uh
so your father has been gone for 15
years
he has
well you're in luck he's here
what'd you do wrong how come he left
yeah what were you doing
why'd you make him leave
[ __ ]
you get bad grades
jenny wishes that her dad stuck around
and touched her on a
train or didn't
like stand up for me that's [ __ ] up
you're watching your son get molested
and you don't say [ __ ]
oh she's already emotionally attached
this is good
he needs a lot of love
jenny he needs to be looked after people
keep trying to molest him you both have
voids that's dope yeah you guys should
try to fill each other's houses yeah
let's uh let's pretend that you're his
father
and grant is a molester
yeah what what would you say how would
you tell him to make him touching your
kid me like young me and i'm just
granted through that off the table but i
won't
hey what's up kid
we the molesters touch oh no that's him
he's oh my god you're lit
so
you're not gonna see anything
crap yeah oh yeah are you oh
just came in his pants
granted no brainer i your dad is
obviously really [ __ ] up
that's not the worst of it but yeah
what's the worst of it yeah do tell
there's a lot of stories here uh
my dad once
took uh child support money from a widow
like
my parents were divorced
sounds like capitalism
he's a good businessman
he was the best advertising sales like
madman you ever seen that show
anyways
um
so your
friend was with donald the great donald
who was recently up here what uh what
makes you such good friends
we met on hinge
we went on a couple dates
you're like i realized some things we
[ __ ] then we became friends with
benefits
and then now it's just friends with no
benefits
now it's just friends
are you holding with emotional benefits
i guess those are fans
we're just friends we're better as
friends
yeah you guys are going out watching
other people date
yeah it's funny you're just looking for
a third basically
no i get that that shit's dope actually
you find a friend from hinge i actually
just went to brunch from a guy used to
date on hinge and like his friends yeah
yeah sometimes you meet it's weird
or it's just a friend vibe yeah you're
like i just you're a cool person yeah
stick around dude i mean austin is small
as you all said yeah
what vibe do you get from grant does he
give you friend vibes or
trained molester vibes i need a dollar
vibes
almost fuckboy vibes
so he's he's probably like
really good with women and he breaks
their hearts
mostly good with women
it's better with trained perverts is
this true grant
kind of how do you like evaluate whether
someone's a [ __ ] boy just by looking at
them
their outfit their hair
their facial hair
so what are the like things keeping me
from [ __ ] boy right now like what gives
you hope
no one said hope grant
is just one more button or what gives me
hope
you said almost [ __ ] boy and i think you
got excited but it just meant like
you're not as hot as most [ __ ] boys
you look like ruby
your shirt looks like one of the walls
in an east austin apartment
this is fun
are you trying to go full [ __ ] boy is
that why you're not
no i'm i'm
i'm looking over into the abyss and i
don't want to go there but how old are
you again 26.
okay
um
you don't want to be a [ __ ] boy is what
you're saying no i know
cut your hair change your shirt
then we can talk
get rid of your dog
[ __ ] no he's i have a golden retriever i
can't get rid of him he's a package deal
what is it package deal golden retriever
i thought you said your dog's name was
don cheadle and i was
wild
what's your dog's name ranger oh
better than a marine
liberty
all right cool i'm glad i made that cool
joke that's reset the room
feels good um
would you guys swipe right on each other
if you saw each other on a date
no
yeah that was a pass for you how about
you sleep right
yeah you would she's gorgeous yeah
pathetic
thank you what's your type jenny
something with color
oh
okay
let's pasty white yeah color right here
whatever
blotches of red
yeah there's some red in there those are
moles now actually hot have those been
checked out
yeah what do you mean by someone with
color
does that mean anyone that's not white
yeah
what's wrong with white men
a lot
how much time but i know i still like i
mean i tan pretty well that's good okay
if you can tan that's better than
some
absolutely it's just the lighting of the
stage too believe me it's a little
better out there
for it she said i wouldn't swipe he's
still going for it i can sell this my
dad would not let me come off the stage
he's still out there jenny what do you
do
i'm a designer oh that's cool what do
you design
software
software
sorry so much more artistic and cool
who do you use for cyber security
how do you design software
maybe more of a monet type company it's
just you put the semicolons in the right
place
the colors the semicolons
what does your page look like from oh
okay so you do websites and stuff
website yeah
exactly
you're like yeah an asian
designer
are you
yeah
grant do you want to try to sell
yes hans i actually would who is your
cyber security provider actually
name name a big one because i
crowdstrike
the best one
what crowdstrike
security sales i know a really good
sales rep
that's not a [ __ ] boy
are you a security broker like wow
i can be if you want me to
that's why he's going on a dating show
live on youtube he's gonna be so good at
cyber security
yeah this is live on youtube yeah
you should start with the
i wouldn't
say it on the tickets you can even
something that you wouldn't want
revealed on youtube
i'm literally not gonna tell you
anything else
okay she's closed off what kind of asian
are you
i am happy enemies okay that's cool half
colonizer happy vietnamese classic yeah
you're the next you're gonna bring
balance to the forest
helya i assume you know my best friend
because she's also vietnamese
and she's up north there's a lot of a
lot of y'all up there don't [ __ ] with
people up north
good answer that's fine
do white up north don't work hello wide
open shut up grant um
jenny where'd you move here from seattle
oh yes yes yes we said that did we say
that
i'm glad you're reloading near there
in seattle
i don't know oh well he's he's been in
portland portland oh and you just
assumed portland is seattle it's pretty
close
so uh you like seattle did you like the
uh vibes there you know you got really
uh you seem like you do well there like
you you ordered lots of complicated
drinks at starbucks or
muddled
anything
no
star
starbucks is great seattle is great
it's lovely that's where i'm at donald
yeah oh yeah
yeah we we go way back oh [ __ ] years
but
i just hate the weather i moved to
austin for a job and
to get some sunshine i know that's
cliche it's important
like how donald keeps moving to cities
with no black people in it
they're like look at the diversity
there's always at least one black person
everywhere i go
you're the only one
oh that's great
but uh grant what do you think about
diversity do you think it's important to
you know hang out with a bunch of
different races
i absolutely think that hans i endorse
hanging out with multiple races what's
the last racially
person motivated person you hung out
with
wait repeat that question who's like the
what's the weirdest race
what's your least favorite race is what
we're asking
oh man um my least favorite race uh gosh
so many tell us that you're diverse
prove it grant
the worst one i hung out with
um
i don't know an indian guy maybe i don't
know
are you talking about your uber driver
no probably someone i was trying to sell
something to and they just kept going
lower and lower i just got frustrated
and you're saying that's your friends
yeah that you have a friend well we go
out a lot and try to get from and they
don't want to go in on it with me and
i'm like come on we both need to eat and
we have to go half on this like no 25
percent like no we gotta do this i hope
you get cancelled
whatever you try to do
selling stuff
i hope you get canceled from somewhere
[ __ ]
all right so you have no friends except
for white people is what you're saying
yeah actually the two friends i showed
up with both happen to be white so
probably yeah what race is david r
he's jewish oh you're david r's friend
yeah oh that sucks
explains everything exactly
so uh jenny what do you think about
going on another date
with another man
with another man besides grant we got
one more name in this bucket
would you want to call him up
you want to call him i'd love to
well it's grant thank you so much for
going
you still have your dog so you're doing
better than david r
we got david coming up
david not david not david r normal david
here he comes from the back
what do we got
moving through the dark got a backwards
hat on
i don't think this will be racially it
might diverse
oh i just really don't want to upset her
it's really my biggest concern you don't
know each other no no no i've just been
watching her from a distance it's pretty
scary you know she's not are you into
her
um
david nice to meet you bud
okay so
um are we starting today we have a like
certain time around tender on a date
with her
try to have sex with him how are you
doing
i'm david nice to meet you great to meet
you yeah um so uh
feed your mountain which one do you like
more
the beach for sure the sunshine what's
your favorite beach you've been here
probably in thailand
lots of beaches over there okay how
about you beach or mountain mountain for
me where
um colorado
i would say i like those mountains a lot
yeah
i i like beach but i like you know
skiing and snowboarding i know cliche
but
no
um yeah so uh what do you i mean i
already watched all of this where did
you move from um i moved here from
houston uh tuesday actually so welcome
yeah i just got here why did you move
here
um i work from home and i have like a
roommate or not a roommate my old
college roommate lives here in austin
and
he said he had a room for rent and so i
just was like why not why didn't you
move to colorado
be by your dreams your mountains you
know honestly i would like to do that
but uh
we have someone at my office that lives
there already so i just they already
cleaned it and time
give it up for jenny again and david
the lover of mountains a lot of shocking
stuff came out here the vietnamese girl
loves the beach and the guy with the
plaid and the trucker hat with the trees
on it likes denver
do you love granola bars
sure man what's your favorite dave
matthews song
so david what's your uh what's your
favorite thing to do on a mountain
go down it i guess go down a mountain oh
we like a man that goes down i mean you
know on or downtown you go to the beach
what do you like to do at the beach i
like to get in the sand and get in the
water i mean you know i'm just saying
okay are you mocking us
am i what mocking us right now how dare
i or what is that
don't make fun of his mountains
he loves him so much he moved to austin
texas yeah it's crazy my bad you guys
got one guy per area you guys can't
double up
um
i mean he already lives in the denver
area and just
i don't know i don't want to challenge
my lap to move to austin to be honest
okay well
welcome thank you for moving here from
houston three days ago
i appreciate you having me man what have
you done here so far besides go on a
date
um
i don't know i went to a volleyball
thing friday
a volleyball thing basketball thing this
morning
so you go watch sports a lot big ball
guys
no you need a flat surface to play
sports like volleyball and basketball
it's hard to play
basketball on a slope there's no
mountain volleyball i i hadn't thought
of the flaws in my plans and desires and
i really screwed that up i'm sorry my
bad jenny
i was so you came from houston
yeah yeah i came to that maybe that's
why you hate beaches
yeah yeah right that's another work yeah
in houston
bad theory yeah we have uh brown water
and brown sand so that's pretty cool and
brown people
we yeah we do have that we do have that
uh sorry about that i love mexican
people
uh jenny what do you think about his uh
opener his beaches versus mountains is
that a common dichotomy what about like
planes versus
you know
trains
there's any
i think it's pretty good what's your
favorite file nobody opens with what do
you do
yeah it's like a team i was trying to
avoid yeah smart i knew the beaches and
uh mountain thing is definitely like a
little cliche as well but that's cool
but people uh are kind of
on one side or the other it's good we
just didn't want to like explain our
jobs to each other in a minute so
i was born and
he's so traumatized
by you guys
absolutely that's fine
so what's like a move that you do on a
date is there like a common thing that
you do on dates that like maybe you
could teach us like just uh like the
same thing on every day yeah how do you
not do that that works okay i would say
you know don't look at your phone uh
get their chair if you can
hell yeah texas boy i love when they do
that [ __ ]
here you go here's your chair the same
thing you can just sit here and not have
an abortion on it
i'm a texas boy
that's why they pull up the chair they
make sure you don't turn it over
jesus
so uh yeah you you you have the texas
chivalry would you ever take jenny on a
date shooting guns because they you
can't do that in seattle shooting guns
um that's not really on like a first
date thing for me yeah
um no i i don't think that would be like
in my thought of doing on the first date
or even first three dates i shot guns a
lot i am from texas but
you don't want to shoot guns with girls
would you shoot guns with me
i mean i'm sure you got a sweet ak-47
you want to show me but i'm not ready
and i think we should wait
we're american a date with you right now
that would be so weird i'm asking
hypothetically dude hypothetically she
likes my dates
i said color
i don't have that black
most colors on my skirt
that's okay that's fine this is a white
boy yeah
so look very cross
are you wearing a cross is that an iron
cross no no it's it was a gift from my
dad he's in the luftwaffe i am a
christian i mean like i'm not a judgey
christian you know but no you southern
boys are the [ __ ]
they know to pull out chairs not gonna
be like how dare you do that cause like
like you said earlier diet catholic
i feel that i'm yeah right christian i
definitely you know believe in all that
but i sin a lot you know i
i can't judge anyone about their sins
you know what i mean yeah unless you're
muslim
holy [ __ ] uh jennifer my amarillo family
not me man
oh yeah those guys are the worst
amarillo
um jenny what what religion do you have
are you like half buddhist half whatever
half atheist
ninety percent atheist
whoa ten percent ten percent
the spotlight is here
just you know go with the flow
i just seem like an odd answer 90
percent atheism i don't know what that
means i'm just curious it's mean she's
most mostly atheist
what uh what what piece of buddhist
wisdom would you have for this
mountain dew guzzling
white boy
he got a lone star he's got a lone star
he shoots tequila
eats red meat i'm guessing
he's into extreme sports
like mountain sports x games
what do you have to teach him maybe
about you know sharing or
not destroying mountain side
don't try to
colonize or
it worked for you girl
yeah without colonization we wouldn't
have jenny
yeah product or
yeah just don't try to convert anybody
you know keep that to yourself the two
c's
what percentage christian answering
questions i'm sorry i didn't mean to do
what percentage christian are you
i would say like 90
90. why 90 why not 100 why not 40.
i don't feel comfortable answering that
you know okay all right
so you're political that's good that's
good what's the what's the latest thing
that you try to colonize recently
i would say the
um room that i just rented i colonized
the [ __ ] out of that and take over that
whole house i brought my mattress in
there yeah that's how it starts adding
white man on a mattress is how america
was conquered let's see if we all know
that answer to that song is good
actually you should check it out ready
but i bet you we already know the answer
did a bed frame come with you
oh yeah it did what up [ __ ] it felt
ladies
it was really nice yeah you got a
foldable bedroom
he's sleeping on a couch
no no no no no no no no no no no that'd
be cool
he called it a foldable bedroom it's
definitely a futon it's just
really good
but yeah no i understand y'all not
thinking i have one but i mean my
posters have frames my bed has what kind
of
how many dave matthews posters
is seven too much
no that's the right amount uh that's
right
scott's number you know
what do you have framed
fight club
no no no boondock saints
just random stuff it's not like movie
posters or anything like that like what
random stuff you got jesus christ you
know
oh it's just like a piece that i it's
just like a bunch of random stuff that i
like put together it's like a collage
thing did you did you do it did i do art
no no no no i i bought the art but it's
like all five you colonized the art they
colonized the art that's correct and
describe it to us
it's like it's like one of each season
of the year and then
there's like uh there's like a
one of space and then one of something
that represents myself
what represents yourself
it's no no no it's not
mountains mountain dew no no it's a can
of mountain dew how'd you know that's
[ __ ] nuts
no no it's it's just like a
it's a picture of a like a guy looking
out the sun is he named it's a guy
looking out into the sun is he clothed
yeah he's close okay which bible figure
does it remind you of
no bible figure which if you were going
to take i said i was a diet christian i
remember saying that and you know what
that means because you said that first
i would just like to complete it yeah
you have a picture of a dude on your
wall that's how dare i
a man shall not lie with another man why
does a man staring at the sun
that's the most douchey part that i was
get there get there
let's go
it's fr it's the guy from lawrence
arabia and it's in a scene where he's
looking out oh that's a colonizer that's
a famous colonizer
you guys should arm wrestle over it
let's do it yeah can you arm wrestle
yeah no i don't want to do that that's
sweet because he's a good southern boy
and he doesn't touch women like that see
i'm on your side i sound scary but i'm
on your side dude we got a mini redneck
and a mini laura croft on stage
we're just gonna go after it and try to
colonize each other
i don't know lawrence of arabia that
well what is what is he famous for
it
it's a movie from like the 60s and it's
like it's like a world war one maybe
like a guy helped he didn't help like he
was part of the process of uniting like
the arabian tribes to fight the turks
and it's it's just it was like a really
it's like the last samurai buff for
middle easterners
sure we need a white man to help us see
that was there it is
there it is
but no it's it's just it has a lot of
good lines in the movie that i liked
what's your favorite line
um stop being ambiguous
um i would say uh no you dirty arabs
shoot that way
not at each other
who told this broad she could drive
of course it hurts but the trick is
simply not mining that it hurts i always
liked that growing up i thought that was
a good say it again it's louder and into
the microphone like lawrence are you
do you mean that or embody the character
yeah of course it hurts the trick is
simply not minding that it hurts oh
that's like rafiki hitting the homeboy
with the stick
yeah just like that actually verbatim
lawrence of arabia frequently known as
the rafiki of arabia
this is his claim to fame
oh why does that resonate with you
that line or that movie uh both um i
just no i just thought that was a good
line uh like i thought that was
i just liked it and uh the movie pain
hurts
sometimes it's a good hurt
you you feel a lot
you feel a lot of emotions man you're
feeling it yeah pisces or virgo no i
actually just you know we avoid emotions
as rednecks apparently you know what i
mean that's men yeah i feel like that's
part of it too yeah i like that [ __ ]
i'm more robotic
you're more toxic tweeting them you're
just not programmed for that i don't
have any
jenny what do you think about this guy
i think he's cute he's not for me but
he's cute jenny's a fire or a libra and
homeboy is like a water sign what's your
sign
i'm a cancer so i'm water oh your evo is
[ __ ] yeah deep down you're a softy very
much oh okay how about you vince okay
i'm a taurus oh so do you cook you big
foodie yeah i actually do cook what do
you cook what's your thing um i mean i
make
uh you know a decent amount of stuff
pizza um steak fish lobster mac and
cheese
get pizza from scratch i've done that
okay it's like woody
uni what like a
do you have your own wood fired stone oh
no i don't have my own yeah i know you
have to say it slowly to me i'm an idiot
i'm sorry about that you and your
roommate have your own wood fired i
literally just moved into my [ __ ]
house i don't know what like i'm still
figuring it out all right okay so who's
this italian broad that i gotta fight
and prove that i'm more italian i knew
you were italian oh my god
you don't like me
she's from the hyena corner say italia
but i said it italian taught me
oh okay so [ __ ] didn't teach how to huh
so chick
female did not teach you how to cook it
she did but it i mean that was like
four or five years i speak in [ __ ]
greek i just wanted to bust your balls a
little bit oh okay well you know that
has real
redneck mac miller vibes
oh my god i didn't see mac miller till
just now
yeah yeah i've heard it what's your
favorite way to do heroin
they do meth down here oh i'm sorry i
didn't mean to be culturally insensitive
i
i forgive you for that you know it
happens what's how do you like to do
math what's the hardest drug you've done
the hardest drug i've done don't say
weed like that person from
ohio i've done acid and mushrooms i
would say that i would say that that's
really hard and that's when you started
watching lawrence of arabia
let me watch it
watching my dad and it was great oh
that's cute yeah okay
how old were you when you were watching
your dad on ass at 14
i mean
i was actually like a thousand years old
at the moment
but uh i feel a thousand years old
listening to you
you got a real slow cadence
some of that happened
real hard here i'm trying real hard i'm
sorry about that what do you think about
this white boy who doesn't even know
about buddhism saying he's a thousand
years old because he did a tab of acid
once he trapped in samsara it's what i
was i was colonizing my bad
i'll take it easy i'm sorry
well said my bad for colonizing you're
you're great at it you know i wouldn't
want to make you not participate in your
culture you're some of the best
colonizers what does your dad do
um he was a lawyer growing up is he
happy
he was yeah no my me and my family are
all really tight i'm really close to my
mother my sister my brother they're
still together yeah they're still
together they're the same people love
each other and it's beautiful mix yeah
they're christian
beautiful mix wait what's your mom my
mom yeah are they just all white people
yeah no we're very white
well you said it's a beautiful mix and i
was like oh we got a beautiful mix of
like the emotions that like they still
have
the same problems that i see young
couples yeah
donald donald says donald sees your
family is like wow look at the diversity
here
we got all different types of white
people they eat steak they eat hot dogs
they eat hamburgers all that stuff
nice
what did you say you do um i i work uh
at a company called helix media we build
like virtual tours and 3d renderings for
like apartments wow
yeah you hate work talk
yeah i do i absolutely do i'm just
trying to figure out your salary
it's pretty good
so what are the benefits
um but yeah i mean you have a diverse
family you know like a good mix of
genders male and female like we have
both actually most families
all two genders right
we grew up with a dog and a cat so
i even had a gerbil that also
disappeared so angel i feel you we lost
all four of our dribbles what was your
name the gerbils yeah nobody knows that
you don't know the germans like in third
grade they're gone you were so emotional
and feeling they were increasing
they named themselves
they were named brunch and dessert yes
they were i guess you get hungry in that
trailer
uh
tell you what we could take that trail
anywhere we want to go down you know
what i'm saying
[Laughter]
give it up for jenny and uh david good
david better david everybody
that was the show
what did you think about the dates
tonight what a wild mix i learned a lot
um
mostly that if a guy is last name that
starts with r he [ __ ] sucks
um
solidified that um
yeah solidified that marines are
fuckboys but also i just hope that man
leaves that girl that is so scary i know
that is so scary for a douchebag i have
a lot of sympathy for you yeah that and
that's like my life story so i kind of
met myself there
and then uh donald [ __ ] great we love
donald we love angel how great was angel
angel was amazing thank you for dealing
with she was amazing david r
marie claire's worker marie claire marie
her friend yeah
very good voice she's gonna narrate this
entire show next week yeah
i will say marie claire and donald z
made me really meet myself and that i
was like i'm a lot of [ __ ] energy
because i was like i would scare the
[ __ ] out of either of these people yeah
and she's a bouncer
[Laughter]
and then uh i [ __ ] with david i like a
southern boy yeah he's confident i hope
jenny finds a nice colored person
need to go to the 60s for that one day
yeah jenny you're gonna make like a
beautiful baby with a colored she's
gonna have like the most beautiful baby
in the future only a quarter colonizer
everyone here works in some sort of text
so that's kind of terrifying yeah
they're all part of skynet
except for marie claire because she'd be
[ __ ] up with the kids
the kids that she hates
but uh
that was a show give it up for gina
hyena
you can find her on all the social media
yes i am bumble
yeah i'm on hinge actually and the
league not to [ __ ] brag but um and
eggs and hot sauce on instagram please
follow me it helps me get booked eggs
and hot sauce
and she's on the league you can book her
you can get her brunch get her eggs and
hot sauce make a reservation give it up
for you guys for coming out thank you
guys so much have a good night thank you
guys
connect together
why